hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time to see what free ps4 games you
may have missed recently this is our
third list I'll check out the other
videos if nothing takes your fancy here
let's use the comment section below to
find like-minded players so pop your
gamertag and the name of the game you
want to play and let the google jump on
board and help you out oh and one last
thing many of these games require PS
plus so please keep that in mind okay
let's do this I'm starting where I left
off last episode with paladin this is a
great arena shooter which has had a
rough ride due to its similarities with
overwatch this is a five-on-five title
with many different game modes including
payloads in which you secure a weapons
cache and this got it to the enemy base
earthwork the payload we got it the last
time I played there was 27 champions to
choose from with various skills and
abilities
I really recommend paladin and it's easy
to learn but takes time to master
I have a video breaking down 9 reasons
why you should try this so I won't waste
any more time talking about it now
next up is one of the games of the year
in my humble opinion
hitman series one before you get too
excited it's not the full game it's just
the first chapter of the story but with
work underway on series 2 this extended
demo could be the title for you in
hitman you try to take out your target
without being noticed
meaning organization and planning and
sometimes last-minute deviations from
the plan are complete improvisations are
called for this is not like the last
hitman game absolution and has multiple
ways to kill each target making it
replayability through the roof who
doesn't want to be a balding man with a
barcode on his head
don't answer that again we snuck onto
the store without any fanfare was
crossed out this is a vehicular warfare
title after the apocalypse it could be a
Mad Max tie-in with the look and feel of
each of the vehicles this one offers AI
opponents or you can test your skills
online too
the game pledges focused around creating
and upgrading your ride to perform
better and rule the sand dunes and
dilapidated robes the amount of
customization is impressive you want to
tank with armor-piercing rounds it's
here how about the military all-terrain
vehicle with twin flame throwers yet
that fear - or even a standard muscle
car with a run-of-the-mill machine gun
found everywhere in the apocalypse so
I'm told
this is not enough to make you want to
try it then look at this beef a freaking
spider tank if you're going to try this
one please put your tag below and I'll
play alongside you
let's look at an earlier game you may
have missed
Paragon this is a MOBA a multiplayer
online battle arena from epic game in
this will you and your team attempt to
get to the opposition side of the map
killing everyone and destroying their
car sounds quite easy well each route to
the car is guarded by a tower to even
the odds resorted can be found but
locating those resources could trigger a
monster encounter team balance is
everything in these types of games so be
sure to learn your defensive and
offensive character classes to do your
team justice the continued introduction
of new characters and the superb support
from the developers give this game a
rightful place in your collection
welcome to the world of parks Nora Hawks
Nora has been around since 2006 but only
made it to PlayStation in May this is a
turn-based strategy game where you'll be
collecting decks of cards to do battle
this one starts of a single-player
experience against an AI opponent
building to online versus mode once
you've improved your skills and deck of
cards I personally could not get into
this one but I'm sure someone out there
loves this game type if it's you then go
on give it a go let's have a classic
side-scrolling beat'em up in the shape
of knights of valour I remember playing
this in the 90s and my word they've done
a good job modernizing the visuals and
controls but keeping the key mechanic in
perfect condition if you're a fan of the
old arcade classics then give this a try
play alone I'll take it online football
player action like many of the games on
the list microtransactions are paying
for this game first as long as you don't
get posing by the allure you can keep
all your money in your pocket are you
Marvel or DC maybe Bokke
well last episode we looked at DC
Universe Online and now Marvel heroes
Omega has joined the fray this is an MMO
where you play from the very first
mission as one of your heroes Wolverine
blade iron man there's so many heroes to
choose from that you'll spend hours
making your first decision but don't
worry you can swap between characters
although you are forced to start each
mission again when you do new characters
are being added but some are behind a
pay wall for example Deadpool is
available
costume will cost real money with 99
players on each server you can invite
everyone you know to hack and flush
their way through every Marvel villain
you can remember
[Music]
people of Earth you're welcome
let's look at Ani theory an online
action role-playing game set in the rich
history of Japanese culture if you have
an interest in Japanese legends folklore
or even fairy tales this one is for you
you'll be battling monsters and building
your combat skills bring along friends
in groups of four and clump together but
don't worry non-playable partners can be
used if you're friendless like me by the
way I thought onigiri translated to rice
cake but I'm assured it means demon
cutter which definitely sounds more
hardcore although I prefer rice rescue
some elements of the game resemble
Monster Hunter and others feel a little
bit like Phantasy Star Online either way
this is a great way to introduce
yourself to this type of game which are
huge in Japan let's go back to the
makers of paladin's hi-rez studios and
one of their other free-to-play titles
smiling this is another MOBA this time
in third person in smite you'll be
playing as a god or goddess or some
other mythical being there's actually
around 90 gods and immortals to choose
from at present from Egyptian North
Roman or even Hindu culture there is
around ten different game modes too with
the most common being conquest in which
two teams of five start with a small
purse of cash purchase started item
these could be ability enhancements or
special skills to gain the edge in
battle the levels play very similarly to
Paragon with the key difference being
the theme of gods in my humble opinion
Paragon has the slicker gameplay but
smite is far more interesting to immerse
yourself into of course everyone's
opinion is different do you play it once
a few more people to gain with what's
your gamertag below and let's find
similar minded people finally another
card game this one in open beta status
I'm sure you've already heard of it but
it's not Gwent this card game took over
my life during my playthrough of witcher
3 this is a turn-based card game between
two people with a deck of cards with
unique abilities the goal is to win two
out of three rounds by strategically
using your offensive and defensive cards
if you win you may be awarded new cards
to extend your deck
if you play half Stone or Magic the
Gathering you'll be right at home here
so that's it ten more games that you can
play for free on your ps4 many games
will try to get you with
microtransactions and the promise of
progression but if you keep your wits
about you and be mindful you'll keep all
your pennies in your pocket if I've
missed any games you think we should
cover please put it in the comments
below
from this list I'll be playing paladin's
and cross out time I don't from
PlayStation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]